when I saw this camera rolled my eyes I
ain't gonna lie like it looked
impressive there but it's just like this
isn't something for me like I don't like
games that that demand like excessive
timing if that makes sense and you can't
get more excessive timing than a rhythm
game right because they demand you to
play the game to the rhythm of whatever
beat that they're playing uh but when I
played it because I was playing a fire
emblem and you know Cog was like uh
addict I know you don't like it I don't
know you don't like these type of games
I'm gonna need you to play the first
boss at least that's like I said it's
like you're in the same pocket I don't
like rhythm-based games generally either
so I was worried I wouldn't drop and
continue I'm sorry mm-hmm yeah but he's
like he's all right so you know
if someone said come on attic just admit
that you got no room
don't you do that so I played the first
one I played the uh the the
I like just the energy the game gives